[Music]
hey everyone
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 21.6 percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like
and subscribe to support the channel
welcome to another installment
of harry potter theory in this video
we're going to be discussing a segment
from the order the phoenix where
everyone's
favorite hogwarts headmistress dolores
umbridge
is brought to justice the 1996 school
year
was rough as it saw hogwarts headmaster
albert dumbledore
vacate the school and dolores umbridge
enter voldemort was back
this was an inevitable fact but
cornelius fudge
who presides over the ministry of magic
was simply blinded by fear
and denied it vehemently dumbledore
implored with fudge to see reason
and to acknowledge that voldemort had in
fact returned
but fudge wouldn't and in response he
slandered dumbledore's name
the daily prophet would release headline
after headline
expressing the slipping standards of
hogwarts
and this is what led to the ministry's
gradual takeover of the school
and umbridge's placement in that same
school year
umbridge also worked as both the defense
against the dark arts professor
and hogwarts high inquisitor she was
massively unpopular among the student
body
with a few exceptions and she'd made the
lives of the students
miserable she would introduce rule after
rule
after rule or educational decree as she
liked to call them
and it got to the point where the
students weren't able to do anything
to make things worse umbridge would
conduct cruel and unreasonable
punishments
on those who violated her rules umbridge
knew
that her connections with the ministry
would allow her to get away with almost
anything
however later on in the book film we
finally see the terrible
umbridge get what was coming to her when
hermione comes up with an impromptu plan
to lead her to the forbidden forest the
ministry
and umbridge suspected the dumbledore
and the order were up to something
which meant that when hermione dangled
the idea of a secret weapon
in front of her she fell right into
their trap then
where is it in there of course it had to
be somewhere that students weren't going
to find it
accidentally didn't it of course of
course
very well then you two stay ahead of me
can we have your wand
then if we're going first no i don't
think so mr potter
the ministry places a rather higher
value on my life
than yours i'm afraid while treading
through the forest
hermione and harry didn't have much of a
plan they just needed to buy some time
all of a sudden however umbridge harry
and hermione
were faced with a band of centaurs and
they didn't look particularly pleased
unsurprisingly umbridge was displeased
with the arrival of the centaurs
and though afraid began to spout off
racial slurs toward them
exercising her extreme prejudice and
arrogance this only angered the centaurs
further
and they began to advance on umbrage at
which point she cast the incarcerous
spell
on one of them this is where the book
and film differ quite a bit
as in the book the centaurs are
successful in overpowering umbrage
without any external help a group of
them carrying her away from hermione and
harry while she screamed for her life
over the plunging many coloured backs
and heads of the centaurs
harry saw umbridge being born away
through the trees by bane
still screaming on stop her voice grew
fainter and fainter
until they could no longer hear it over
the trampling of hooves surrounding them
at this point the remaining centaurs
actually turned on harry and hermione
as hermione had accidentally insulted
them when trying to explain to the
centaurs that she and harry were not
like umbrage
that they had no affiliation with the
ministry of magic she mistakenly
mentioned
that she wanted the centaurs to drive
umbrage off for them
this deeply offended the centaurs as
they felt that this was just another
pair of arrogant wizards
that felt the centaurs existed to serve
them because of this
the centaurs decided that they would
attack before being attacked
however hagrid's half-brother group
intervened
gorp is first introduced to us earlier
in the book film
when hagrid brings the trio to the
forest to make introductions
hagrid discovered his brother grope
while making a trip to the tribe of
giants
in 1995 on albus dumbledore's orders
dumbledore wanted the giants as allies
if things were to kick off with
voldemort
and given that hagrid is a half giant
dumbledore felt that he was the man to
send
after spending three days at the giant's
camp hagrid eventually discovered
that he has a half-brother group the
pair share a mother
a giant tess by the name of fred walther
and when hagrid recognised that grope
was being bullied by the other giants
for his small 16-foot stature hagrid
took group with him
back to hogwarts knowing that he'd
likely wouldn't be able to keep grope
in plain sight hagrid kept grope in the
forbidden forest for months
teaching him manners and pieces of
english though hagrid's attempts at
domesticating group were largely futile
hagrid cared for him very much and it's
a good thing he was around
because he was the reason that harry and
hermione were able to survive their
encounter with the centaurs
recognizing that harry and hermione were
in danger group intervened
and despite taking a multitude of arrows
to the face was able to successfully
chase the centaurs
away in the film however after umbridge
casts the incarcerate spell on the
centaurs
she is suddenly picked up by group and
with her arms flailing
the centaurs capitalized on her
suspension in mid-air
and took the opportunity to capture her
though some stray arrows hit group in
the process
after they had captured umbridge the
centaurs were satisfied
and simply fled however the question
remains
why didn't umbridge simply use magic on
group and free herself from his grasp
after all she was picked up by the
scruff of her neck
which meant that both of her arms were
free surely she could have cast some
sort of spell
couldn't she why would she just angle
there desperately and allow the centaurs
to take control of the situation
i have a few theories for why this may
have happened the first reason that she
may not have fought back
is because she didn't have a wand as far
as i can tell from the scene in the film
umbridge doesn't have a wand in her hand
one less magic
or at least powerful oneless magic is
not as common as you may think
and it may just be that umbridge never
took the time to hone the use
of her magical abilities without her
wooden vessel
the next reason for why umbridge may not
have fought back is the fact that group
is a giant
it's well known in the wizarding world
that certain magical creatures
giants included have hides that repel
all but the most concentrated and
powerful spells
umbridge recognizing that she'd been
picked up by a creature which was
resistant to most of her magic
had no other option than to demand that
grope put her down
the third and final reason for why
umbridge may not have fought back
is that she was simply caught completely
off guard in one moment
umbridge was at the hogwarts castle in
complete control
and in the next she was entirely out of
her element totally alone
facing off against a band of centaurs
the last thing that she expected
was to be picked up by a giant and there
was very little time between her
actually being picked up
and when the sentinels jumped at the
opportunity to capture her
umbridge's fate certainly seemed
uncertain for a while
but she was eventually rescued by
dumbledore
how he managed to rescue her is
untelling but many magical creatures
did have a considerable amount of
respect for albus as shown by the salute
at his funeral the experience for
umbridge was traumatic nonetheless
and she was left with a deep fear of
centaurs for the rest of her life
what do you guys think why was umbridge
so helpless
did you guys notice the difference
between the book and film versions of
this scene
let me know down in the comment section
below until next time
you're a wizard howie
you